Die Hauptaufgabe des österreichischen Bundesheeres
ist die militärische Landesverteidigung.
Um diese im Ernstfall gewährleisten zu können,
befinden sich die Soldaten im ständigen Training.
Aber auch in Friedenszeiten sorgt das österreichische
Bundesheer Tag für Tag dafür,
dass alle Österreicherinnen und Österreicher in Sicherheit leben können.
Beispielsweise durch Assistenzeinsätze an
den Grenzen Österreichs.
Falls notwendig, werden Soldaten an den Staatsgrenzen postiert,
um eine illegale Einwanderung nach Österreich zu verhindern.
Doch nicht nur die Staatsgrenzen werden geschützt,
auch ausländische Botschaften
und andere wichtige Einrichtungen werden vom Bundesheer überwacht.
Für den Schutz der Bevölkerung sorgt auch der Entminungsdienst,
noch immer werden bei Grabungsarbeiten, aber auch in Flüssen und Seen,
Munition und Bomben, die noch aus dem zweiten Weltkrieg stammen, gefunden.
Damit diese keinen Schaden anrichten können, rücken die Mitarbeiter des Entminungsdienstes
mehr als 1000 mal pro Jahr aus und entschärfen die Funde.
Doch nicht nur für Gefahren im Boden, sondern auch über dem Boden, ist das Bundesheer bestens gerüstet.
Die Luftstreitkräfte des österreichischen
Bundesheeres behalten den Luftraum
rund um die Uhr im Auge.
Um gegen die virtuellen Bedrohungen der Neuzeit gewappnet zu sein,
verfügt das Bundesheer über modernste Technik und hochspezialisiertes Personal.
Diese Experten sorgen für den Schutz von
wichtigen Einrichtungen der Informationstechnologie
und damit für die Sicherheit der Österreicher im Internet.
Was aber, wenn ein großes Unglück geschieht?
Wenn beispielsweise starker Dauerregen ein Hochwasser verursacht,
wenn Lawinen oder Muren abgehen und zur Gefahr werden,
Dann rücken die Soldaten des Bundesheeres
zum Assistenzeinsatz aus,
unterstützen die zivilen Hilfsorganisationen und sorgen so
für den Schutz und die Sicherheit der österreichischen Bevölkerung.